let's kiss goodbye
[Music]
people are calling you the new Elvis of
country how does that feel
uh it's pretty wild I mean I'm obviously
a big Elvis fan so uh you know it's high
price
you're out in Dallas Fort Worth debut is
number one on iTunes and like you're
you're shot up to the top my man what
went through your mind when that
happened it's kind of surreal you know
you spend so much time working on a
record like that and then to have it
jump up the charts like that it's pretty
cool
how are you adjusting to all the
attention that you've been getting since
AGT it's kind of a new thing for me but
it's really cool to see that you know my
music is is reaching people uh a long
ways away
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
is there a piece of advice that you've
gotten from any of the judges from Simon
for example that really sticks with you
in the auditions Simon uh commented that
I was authentic and that really meant a
lot the song I had was really really
good as well it was really authentic
that's what I liked about it yeah
especially as a country artist you you
spend a lot of time just trying to be
authentic and try to be true to yourself
and so to to get that uh that kind of
phrase was pretty cool